you know um donald trump is not the
caricature that they make him out to be
and you know i i just i
i there are certain little vignettes
that i remember
you know when when my kids would be we'd
go we'd fly down to florida we had a
house and of course he had mar-a-lago um
and and he would say very quietly to his
kids
don't talk to her like that you don't
talk to your sister like that you don't
talk to him like that never raised his
voice
you know he was always serious and then
when he got
a little more upset it would be no no
emotion you just lost your allowance
keep it up keep it up he was always
attentive to their behavior
and how they acted toward each other
so let's back up for a second because
because you know trump and a lot of my
audience you know a bit about my
political evolution and that i was
i was a bernie supporter and a
progressive and a lefty and all those
things and i
you're good you're a pro you're a pro i
should be judged accordingly
for all of those things um but i know
that there's a lot of my audience
that i would say they don't consider
themselves conservative per se
or even on the right but they consider
themselves what i would say is sort of
the disaffected liberal and i think that
is a
huge huge amount of people in america
right now the liberals that just can't
believe how bananas the left has gone
but i think the other piece of that is
they just find
something about trump off-putting
whether it's the way he speaks or the
tweeting or or whatever something like
that
so since you know him and you talked
about it a little bit already can you
just
if you wanted people to be more okay
that that he does love this country that
he's a decent guy
and it took me a long time to get there
by the way i think i mentioned this on
your show it wasn't until i actually met
him and i had about 10 minutes to talk
to him
that that i felt more okay when he when
he literally turned to my husband and i
and he goes you guys are gay he goes
that's great your only problem is you're
too handsome and i thought this is the
guy who
says everyone's a home you know they say
he think that he's a homophobe
um but since you know him a little bit
more yeah can you just dive into that
you know um donald trump is not the
caricature that they make him out to be
and you know i
i just i there are certain little
vignettes that i remember
you know when when my kids would be we'd
go we'd fly down to florida we had a
house and of course he had mar-a-lago
um and and he would say very quietly to
his kids
don't talk to her like that you don't
talk to your sister like that you don't
talk to him like that never raised his
voice
you know he was always serious and then
when he got a little more upset it would
be
no no emotion you just lost your
allowance
keep it up keep it up he was always
attentive to their behavior
and how they acted toward each other and
and i i'll never forget it was
it was toward the beginning of of uh
school or
uh no the second semester i guess and he
said
when we land we're going to kmart to get
our school supplies you said to the kids
and i'm like
donald trump goes to kmart wow
but when we would walk down the street
in manhattan we went out with him a lot
he was always kind to me he would say to
people you know this janine pirro she's
a d.a you know from westchester and i
was always on television for something
and um and he was always
more um you know he was beholding and
trying to get people to
to recognize you instead of him
whenever he saw a cop whenever he saw a
construction worker a hard hat
and they were all enamored with him they
were like oh hi
and they didn't have phone cameras maybe
back then but they
say can i shake your hand he would
absolutely do it
whenever we'd go into a restaurant and
have dinner or something
he'd march right into that kitchen and
take care of everybody in the kitchen
he is a good generous man
and his kids are a testament to the
success
uh that he instilled in them every one
of them i mean those kids are smart
they're successful
they're brilliant they really are and as
a human being
you know you go through tough periods in
your life for your career
he was always there for me or you know
for my then husband he was
always there always generous in spirit
loved his brother robert i was at the
white house for the uh
uh for the wake uh was
very very sad about that um very family
oriented dave
they were always together he was with
his sisters and his brother
um and never drank and i remember when i
interviewed him in 2016
right before um he ran
uh he was there was talk of him running
and i said you want to tell people
you don't drink he said no i don't drink
never had a drink and people were
floored by that but i've seen him in
parties
all hours of the day and night go to
mar-a-lago everybody be
you know half in the bag not donald
trump
he i love the guy he's a wonderful
wonderful man
and he loves this country and you know
what i don't know anyone dave who could
take the assaults that he's taken
on a daily basis and survive them the
guy looks better than ever
usually after four years you're you're
exhausted
he's raring to go no i know he's he's
more bronze than usual now it's it's
very it must be because of peace in the
middle east that it made in bronze or
something but but speaking of
the human side of things i've had a
bunch of the fox hosts on
and you know you guys all just get
endlessly trashed in the media and
you get the media matters boycotts and
they go for your sponsors and all of
that stuff
and i don't know how comfortable you
comfortably you'll be talking about this
but you did mention to me once how
it can take a toll you know when you're
when you're in your town and oh there's
judging and she's on
fox and just dealing with some of some
of that kind of hate and yet you always
have a smile on your face i mean
what what's that like just just being
you you live in new york
you're a public person and you got to
deal with some
some pretty hateful stuff yeah i do i do
but you see
the difference for me is um i ran for
office five times
i am hardened with steel uh and
uh i'm used to it i mean i used to
boycott me for this or that or i'd
prosecute a case they didn't like it
or uh you know you know i really don't
care
if if you care enough that
uh you're thinking about changing your
mind then care
and change your mind but if you're if
you believe that what you're doing is
right i don't give it a second thought
but what i am amazed uh at or with
is the fact that people on the left
dropped me
you know when trump got elected and my
friends dropped me and i was like but i
would never drop you
you know i i just wouldn't it all
started
you know we all got dropped and i i
found that hurt that hurt
i know the feeling it hurt and you know
when you try
you know to to not maybe sound as crazy
and then you just say you know what i am
who i am it's a short visit here dave
all of us are here for a short time and
if you if you can't be
who you are and if you don't know who
you are
then you better you know reintroduce
yourself to yourself and uh get moving
so i have i have no regrets and i also
uh don't worry about those people uh and
i also am a gun owner i have six guns
uh as you know i am i am a new gun owner
so
uh we we share some things in common so
you end the book
uh fittingly with the closing statement
so i feel that we should end this uh
interview with a closing statement
i mean if if someone picks up your book
and we're
six weeks now roughly but when the book
comes out about five weeks before
the election what is it that you want
them to take
more than anything else from the book
i want people to recognize that uh
it is it's not just about the lies i
mean i
identify the lies and i go through the
lies but the most important thing for
them to understand is that there's a
quote from abraham lincoln
uh from his speech at lyceum where he
talks about
the destruction of this country will not
come from a foreign source
it will come from within and that's what
we're facing right now
we're facing an absolute um
destruction of america as we know it
from forces within america
and we can't let that happen if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell